travailleuses travailleurs
oui je m'adresse à vous en particulier
bien que cela fasse sourire
dédaigneusement tous ceux qui méprisent
les travailleurs durant et c'est le cas
de tous les grands candidats qui font
semblant de traités de la même façon le
temps d'une élection
un chômeur et le milliardaire comme
bouygues pour s'aplatir ensuite devant
le second et envoyer les crs contre le
premier l'égalité par le bulletin de
vote est une tromperie
oui que nous soyons ouvriers employés
techniciens en activité réduit au
chômage et retraités
nous avons tous un point commun celui
d'être des travailleurs et les autres
ceux qui ne tiennent leur fortune que de
notre travail parce qu'ils appartiennent
au patronat au monde de la finance à la
bourgeoisie ont des intérêts
diamétralement opposées aux nôtres
dans le camp des travailleurs il y à
aussi nombre d'artisans de petits
commerçants de petits paysans qui ne
vivent eux aussi que de leur travail qui
sont tout aussi exploité par les banques
les circuits de distribution par le
capital même s'il ne l'admettent pas
toujours oui il y a deux camps dans
cette société
et moi je m'adresse au camp des
travailleurs parce que c'est mon camp je
m'adresse à vous
simplement parce que je suis l'une
d'entre vous parce que je suis une
salariée et que je partage vos problèmes
vos angoisses devant les fins de mois
difficiles vous inquiétude pour l'avenir
pour nous les travailleurs il n'y a rien
à attendre de ces élections
présidentielles rien l'homme qui
s'installera à l'elysée quel qu'il soit
n'est pas de notre monde
ce qu'il sait de nos problèmes il est
obligé de la prendre dans des dossiers
que lui préparent des gens payés pour
cela le chômage pour lui ce sont des
chiffres pour nous pour moi c'est un
père un frère une amie qui désespère et
s'enferme lentement dans la gêne les
salaires mais qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
en savoir les hommes qui nous gouvernent
ils ne comptent pas comme nous vous
croyez qu'ils ont essayé de vivre eux
avec moins de 4000 francs par mois et
même avec 6000 à 8000 francs
non bien sûr et leurs hommes politiques
et leurs économistes ont le culot de
nous
dire qu'il faudra que les patrons
puissent embaucher n'importe quel
chômeurs pour 3000 peut-être 2000 francs
par mois
comme avec les tubes qu'elle et civp
dans cette élection
les jeux sont déjà pratiquement fait
nous ne savons peut-être pas lequel de
mitterrand chirac ou bas sera finalement
élu mais nous savons déjà que ce sera
l'un des trois et ne nous faisons pas
d'illusions celui-là fera la même
politique que les deux autres une
politique en faveur de la bourgeoisie
une politique contre les travailleurs
on dit de moi dans la presse que je dis
toujours cela toujours la même chose
et bien figurez vous que j'en suis fier
et il faut croire que certains
journalistes préfèrent les hommes
politiques qui sont capables de changer
de langage de renier leur promesse de
retourner leur veste est de ceux là
il n'en manque pas que de promesses
n'avons nous pas entendu de barbus de
chirac
mais les deux ont pourtant déjà été chef
du gouvernement pendant des années de 74
à 76 et 2,86 à aujourd'hui pour chirac
de 76 à 80 pour bar pourquoi n'ont ils
pas fait alors ce qu'ils promettent
aujourd'hui et mitterrand oui c'est vrai
je vous disais déjà en 1974 que les
travailleurs n'avaient rien à attendre
de lui
s'il arrivait un jour au pouvoir je leur
disais en 1981 et je le redis
aujourd'hui où il déclare qu'il est prêt
à choisir un gouvernement appuyé sur une
partie des députés de l'actuelle
majorité de droite et pour nous les
travailleurs rien ne va changer ce que
promet mitterrand c'est la paix sociale
pour le patronat il se présente comme
l'homme politique le plus apte à
convaincre les travailleurs de rester
tranquille et il dit à la grande
bourgeoisie que cela vous bien
d'accepter un petit impôt sur la fortune
car ce serait un petit impôt à titre
d'assurance contre la colère des
travailleurs et des chômeurs mitterrand
dit en substance à la bourgeoisie à son
quant à lui qu'il est le seul des trois
pour lequel les travailleurs vont voter
même s'il ne leur promet rien c'est
pourquoi nous ne devons pas approuvé à
l'avance une politique qui se fera de
toute façon contre nous que ce soit par
chirac ou mitterrand qui la mène
nous devons dire que le monde du travail
on a assez des promesses non tenues
assez du chômage de la baisse des
salaires
des soupes populaires nous devons
distinguer nos voix de ceux qui sont
dans l'autre camp et si je vous propose
de le dire
en votant pour ma candidature ce n'est
pas pour mes lire ni pour me procurer un
quelconque strapontin dans un ministère
même de gauche mais pour compter tous
ceux qui sont dans le camp des
travailleurs servez-vous de mon nom pour
le faire car c'est le seul vote qui ne
sera pas ambiguë et si je vous dis voter
arlette aiguiller c'est pour vous dire
votez pour le camp des travailleurs voté
pour la politique des travailleurs